Okay, Michael, so I wanted to,
before diving into a couple of examples,
I wanted to remind you of
a conversation that we had earlier.
Does this little picture
look familiar to you?
>> It looks like the Monte Carlo
tree search stuff we talked about in
the options lesson.
>> It actually is.
So, here's the point that I wanted,
I made the point at the time, but
I wanted to really kind
of drive it home here.
If you recall, I asked you to come up
with some options for solving Pac-Man.
And you came up with four of them.
Do you remember what they were?
>> Yeah, I think they're on a slide,
fortunately.
I just have to remember what they mean.
It's like eat with three
different bullets,
and they're getting successively larger.
But I think it's actually food pellet,
power pellet, monster or
ghost, and then avoid ghost.
>> And avoid ghost.
Right.
And if you recall, at the time
we briefly discussed that these
things really do look like options.
And this last one doesn't really look
like an option in the sense that it
doesn't have a goal and
there's something you can succeed.
In some sense you can only fail.
And this turned out to be
interesting for a couple of reasons.
One, just because you came up with them,
and in fact we've done this study
multiple, multiple humans at
various levels of expertise.
And, basically,
they all come up with the same four.
Sometimes they'll come up with a fifth
that kind of distinguishes between
eating a real ghost that's edible and
a ghost that isn't edible,
and that kind of thing.
But basically,
they come with the same four.
And the point here, and why I want to
bring it up is that if you just ask
people to give you what they know,
you ask them to communicate,
you ask them to coach an agent.
They will often come up with
things that are different from
what your machine expects.
And the sort of claim I want to make is
that often in research what we do is we
come up with wonderful machine learning
algorithms, decide what information they
need, and then try to force humans
to give us that information.
But actually, human beings will
naturally sometimes give us that
information, but often give us
different kinds of information.
And if you look at it the wrong way,
you would say, well, look,
these three are useful.
This last one can't be implemented,
so I'm going to ignore it.
But in fact, even in the Monte Carlo
tree search example,
this last one, this constraint,
actually helped us
develop a better algorithm because it
gave us a better rollout strategy.
And, in fact,
as the students listening will know,
because they've read the paper
on this that we made available,
that it actually improves
performance an amazing amount.
So, the point of this is that when
we ask humans to communicate,
to be a part of the sort
of team of how we teach and
demonstrate to our agents, we need to
meet them where they are as opposed to
try to force them to meet us
where our algorithms are.
>> And I want to give you just
a couple examples of that.
That sound fair?
>> Yeah, that's really cool.
>> Cool.
All right.
So, the first one's going to be
something called policy shaping.
And as a preview, just want you
to know the whole point of this
is to say that all the stuff you talked
about with the word shaping was wrong.
>> Yeah.
Let's take a look.